all right thank you everyone thank you
for having me amigo I lead consumer data
science organization of Twitter I'm
based in the San Francisco office so if
I look jet lag is because I am I'll be
talking about scaling the design team
before I start I would ask like how many
of you are on leadership position so
management or being tech lead or team
lead overall good how many you would
like to be in a leadership position some
point of your careers all right that's
good
not many people anyways I before I
started like to give you a little bit of
context about me I since I was in
college always been fascinated with data
data science data visualization it's
particularly social network data so the
mix of art and information has always
been fascinating in in grad school I
started scraping data of Twitter like
back then it was like 10 years ago and
even still now just like one of the
examples of fascinating dataset that's
public that's real time and that's easy
to to grasp right so this I already
joined Twitter for this case but this
was in 2011 for the earthquake in Japan
we got like all tweets over san about
the earthquake like immediately after
the earthquake happened and plot them in
this map this is the pink lines you see
like where the tweets were seen around
the world and then on green you will see
like people retweeting those tweets and
you see like how in a couple of minutes
information about the earthquake went
through when when around the world and
people were like inform right about the
earthquake the tsunami and they had like
information from firsthand so seeing
like millions of pieces of information
just flying around the world in minutes
was pretty incredible 2010 I joined
Twitter during 2000 intern I was doing
the Association work and then after my
internship I joined on a full-time
capacity I was a researcher this.d was
sort of like my timeline in
this is a very summarized version of it
I join us an internet became manager
joined the dark side of Management 2013
and then 2018 a third matter in this
data science organization so this time
twitter has grown a lot when I joined it
was 150 people 150 employees today like
about 4,000 and at the same time this
practice of data science started growing
too right if you go to trends local come
and look at the trend for people
searching for data scientists you're
gonna see the HR like this over this
same time period
so these practice like I started to
attract people to become like like very
important so this this before I go on
and start talking about how to structure
data science team so I I want to give
you a couple of caveats so first this as
a train data scientist uncompelled to
tell you this talk is based on one data
point but well it's more like a nine
year longitudinal study right like where
I've seen this place change the data
science practice on the way we structure
work and teams has changed a lot too i
presenting in size or my own experience
an opinion so my perspective and this
may be true for place where you are the
place we were but it may not right like
it's cultural differences the size of
company the industry so take this with a
grain of salt and just as my opinion on
perspective first of all I hope like I'm
just going to skim through this because
I hope like this community knows what
era sciences but given the differences
in the definition of data science
depending on where you are and the
industry you are so and I feel compelled
to just like give a brief summary of
where I am here so when there's like
some sort of ambiguity I'll try to
default one source that a lot of people
can access in this case Wikipedia in
these guys not helpful particularly for
this context because if you look at this
definition like there's a lot of big
words right data science is the same
contact
concept as data mining and big data
talks about using the most powerful
Hardware most powerful programming
systems and the most efficient
algorithms but is just too complicated
so I prefer this kind of like Venn
diagrams that
you came up with it just easier to
explain right like data science is the
intersection between programming math
and statistics and domain knowledge or
substantive expertise simple right
well obviously like being so simple like
not everyone is content so people start
building on top of this came up with
this beauty right here so beautiful Venn
diagram a lot of particular
intersections and then you know one
thing led to the other and someone came
up with this I don't know what's going
on that's great
anyway so here's some resources you like
to read more about what their science is
since blog posts on Hacker News about
water nerd is data science it's a first
chapter of the doing they're a science
book by Kelly O'Neil and research throat
which talks about the what is data from
the whole book is great and you know it
San Francisco we like to say that they
are scientists the data analysts who
lives in California I'm told that you
can't replace California with Singapore
can words it kind of works all right so
I spend the rest of time like talking
about structuring teams a lot of these
particular of data science but a lot of
it also applies to engineering teams
they are engineering teams particular
and ml inch teams so there's there's two
typical models of data science teams or
the way like data science is organized
on a particularly not engineering driven
organization so the first one is the
embedded model the second one is the
centralized model like to talk a little
bit about these other glance at talk to
you about the pros and cons of each of
these models in an embedded model you
have an engineering team some
engineering team that's managed by an
engineering manager and then you have a
data scientist as part of this team so
this could be like a full start team
where you have a front-end engineer back
an engineer service engineer some ml
engineers and then you have a data
scientist this team is managed by
typically by someone who knows the
engineering portion of the job very well
if you zoom out and think about
engineering organization in this area
you have in this case like four teams of
engineers and each team finding one
there are scientists so your investment
on data science is just four people but
these data scientists are not working
with each other they may be far away on
the organization structure the main
be even like aware what each other's is
working on like the their focus is to
make the team they are part of work now
the centralized model you have a team of
there are scientists who is managed by a
data science manager and these data
science manager typically knows there
are science very well they know
stakeholder management and and they know
how to manage their a scientist in
particular when you zoom out an
organization with this model then you
have typically an engineering
organization and then a centralized team
of there are scientists that work to
support these teams and this case could
be just one team of there are scientist
aport in this these three teams so pros
and cons to both of this talk briefly
over these pros on the belly model you
have a dedicated resources right like
you have these data scientists who's
part of your team that person or that
group of people it can be two three
people are always there they are part of
the team so you can predict like how
many hours of this person you have you
can plan ahead on your own mod and so on
there's better alignment between data
science and the rest of the team because
that person is on all the meetings is
part of planning process and so on
there's one troll map so the few
dependencies and data has a more natural
sit at the table by data means that you
do some work some data science work that
may end up like influence in the road
map or so and it's easier for the team
sorta like grasp that since you're part
of the team and the money is the same as
the money of the engineers so that
person can influence the Roma on the
work so some of the calls we have here
is a real resourcing
so I mentioned that you have like the
team has won their scientists why did
the team only needs half of other
scientists like what if they actually
don't need all the time when there are
science is through a quarter so so here
either you have a person or like one or
many terror scientist or Jaedong so
there's barriers for collaboration
between there are scientist I mentioned
that if you have like for their
scientists in an Oregon flight 100
people and they are sitting far away
they may be like doing the same sort of
like work all - all over again like is
instead of using building blocks for the
same framework or they may not be
standardizing the same methodology to do
like a be test experimentation and so on
that the the manager may not have the
domain knowledge right we mentioned this
usually a team does management
engineering manager so these people are
typically managed like engineers which
can work in some settings but it doesn't
work with everyone and there's the risk
of their assign as being just a support
function right if you're a data
scientist in the team then everyone
comes to you - or I need a dashboard or
I need you to do a data pool or so on so
the decentralized model also has some
set of like pros and cons in terms of
like the good you have data scientists
working together so they share knowledge
they they train themselves a mentor each
other they are day-to-day basically
talking to each other and see what
everyone is working on the manager
typically again is this person that
knows the practice very well Twitter I
think all the managers were data
scientists before being there are
science managers so the per this person
is able to the data scientist in the
team are able to receive better career
development advice and they are managed
in a better way typically the resources
can be rebalance so you have a team of a
data scientist here what if this team in
a quarter doesn't need any tier assigns
support and this team needs doubled and
you can sort of like handle that because
you controlled a lot of these people on
the whole map and so on and then you you
have this group of people working
together so you can advocate for better
tooling from the company you can have
better data set and so on because you
can spend some of your time as there are
science team making those things a
little bit better it comes with some
negatives too if you do like this purely
centralized approach so the coordination
between teams and let's say you do some
data science work and that data science
will come up with some result to say we
should do X T in the product it's not
like you can just go ahead and do it
need to go to the solar team and
coordinate with them ensure that our
work has priority so it adds this layer
of coordination in engineering Centrex
organization the data science team needs
to influence the roma which is just
slightly what i mentioned and the same
thing with problem and at the end the
company needs to support one more
functions and the previous approach
here you have an engineering
organization you have some data
scientists on it in this case you have a
data science team and you need to start
thinking about if you're growing you
have a terrorist organization that needs
a career ladder than need a vision
shorter and a leadership team and so on
so there's some overhead that adds into
it so we've been through like iterations
of each of these where some point we
have there a scientist and Baron teams
some points we centralize them and then
I we about a year and half ago vulovic
can do can we do better we get to this
perfect world when we have the process
of the embedded model and the process of
the centralized model we kind of like
had to do that so Myung jus scale that
of the operation where I mentioned you
have three engineering teams and one
they're a science team
I do like triple done right you end up
having three times the amount of
engineers three times I'm a data
scientist and you just say okay I'm
gonna do the same thing that I did about
three times so you end up with something
like this right well you have let's say
let's put some labels into these teams
you have a crowd engineering team of a
product engineering team and health
engineering team and then you have data
scientists working with all this if you
just stay here and do this then you
basically have the embedded model at the
team level right like this these data
scientists here are just supporting
growth so they only have visibility
growth is doing same thing for products
same thing for health but what if you
put a layer over here just create an
organization of data scientists right
you have them organized a like the
organization is aligned together you
have many years were trained on data
science and career development and so on
but at the same time you keep that
structure of work with the growth area
scientists are working with the crowd
engineers and so on 74 products safety
for health then you end up having this
sort of like hybrid right well you have
an organization that reports to group of
the design is a report centrally but
then they were they sit down with
engineers they have one robot with
engineers and product teams and so on
so one of the benefits of doing this
that you end up having collaboration
both sides right like you end up having
data science teams who are talking to
each other sharing knowledge sharing
methods standardizing on the way they to
data science in general and so on and
then you have this vertical alignment
when certain subsets of these data
scientists are become like domain
experts on the Prolog areas and actual
soup engineering area that they are
supporting it so we go to engineering
meetings they know what the priorities
are they know what they need to focus on
they know what as from them they know
what kind of work they will do that
wouldn't have an impact so they try to
avoid it and so on so benefits of these
structures I mentioned there's the
centralized processes or even the things
like hiding like you have one hiding
pipeline for there a scientist instead
of hiding from many different places
same thing for onboarding Career
Development you have common resources
framework data set regardless of team
that they are because it's a group of
people who you can't you can get a small
percentage of them to work on making the
practice better there's a few letters
the best of tours here where you have
organizational and Imin between all
their scientists but then you have work
alignment within there are scientists of
the engineering teams that they support
now is it perfect
see that's it like we call it success
well no like we we've been doing this
for a year and a half now we had a bunch
of lessons learned we have challenges
and the main challenge is that everyone
has at least two teams like if you go
back to these if you're here then you're
part of the data science organization
and then you're part of the proud of the
health engineering team which means that
there's like twice amount of meetings
twice the amount of planning twice the
matter of even like social connections
at work and so on and that adds a lot
like we have people telling us hey I
have the same meeting twice in a week
because the engineering team decided to
Rome a planning meeting and then the
organization decided to the same then
that adds also some confusion well it
was my main team my part to the
engineering team or my part of the data
science team so there's also a recent
mismatch between expectations on
leadership let's say
I as a person who lived consumer data
science even wanna steer the team in one
direction and then the engineering
leadership wants to steer the work into
a different direction but there's
Studies layer of coordination that needs
to happen where people need to be in the
same place now we talk about structure a
little bit or we talk about how to feed
their engineers into an engineering
centric world so let's talk a little bit
about how to organize the Dia's worker
scale so in the previous example we
talked about about 20 people
organization right when you have like
three teams engineers one team data
scientist and so on let's say we want to
scale this up we one now to have 80-100
data scientists working at a company how
do you scale this like all structure
does hybrid that has is centralized or
structure for this alignment with the
work with engineering teams
the way we've been approaching this is
just like we just clearly a level of a
layer of instruction when you script
group teams into teams of team so we
call them pillars how do we do that like
we just group people who like to work it
with each other we line people who work
at the same office
well it's we try to we try different
approaches well work best for us to find
objectives to align people on and I'll
explain what I mean by that so I I'm a
computer engineer by education and like
to think about things and systems in
this case you can think about a product
as a system particular consumer product
where you have inputs outputs and then
you have a couple of like measurement
devices and lifting devices so on so you
can think about a prologue module I can
app as a system where you have like
customer acquisition coming in so you
want more customers to come in join
those customers to stay you want to
retain them and you want to monetize
them right like you wanna be ensure that
these keeps running and then you this
only works if you have like some
monitoring devices like to monitor
things like health and integrity
and then you have some foundation so
think about if these are car in needs
fuel in its oil and so on to work right
so those are the foundations if you
translate that to some of the
teams that are ready mention
organizations you can think about is
like growth there are science work being
for customer acquisition so how do we
unborn users how do can we do better
marketing to to have people discover our
services and so on and then in terms of
retention you can think about the
product that assigns words so how do
people if you think about Twitter how do
people how can we make people use the
home timeline more and then I won't
mention these too much because it's our
server or but you wanna you wanna
understand how to monetize gonna do
better signs were to understand like how
to increase your revenue and then you
wanna ensure like again to have to do a
lot of work and is actually one of our
top top priorities to understand how you
can make these experience a healthy one
I like free of misinformation and abuse
and finally that fuel and oil that I
mention is things like data engineering
metrics insights data visualization some
of these practices or tools that make
the work better not just for data
scientists good for thought managers who
need access to data and so on so that it
they lift each other and that's the way
we serve like organized or growing data
science organization when you have four
P four pillars each pillar has about
three to five teams and they are all
aligned by very simple objectives so one
is we want to add users one we want to
add activity or customer satisfaction
one is we want to ensure that the system
is healthy and then one we wanna
increase productivity efficiency of the
people who are working the data
scientists and our customers and I'm not
gonna go to this but this is some of the
things that we do on each of these
pillars some of these are dedicated
teams looking into either one or a
couple of days and then in red are the
practices that we actually support from
our Singapore office just in case any of
you is interested in any of this so you
talk about structure teams or structured
data science work we talk about
organizing work on a scaling
organization now how do you keep these
teams together so we mentioned an
organization like this I mean it looks
kind of pretty because everyone has
teams one manager I mean that was just I
mean Rojas every team has eight people
one manager that was just for my
personal convenience of being able to
copy and paste these multiple times in
reality like something's are three
people five people and actually some
managers may have two or three teams so
that was junks gonna be too hard to to
draw here but my point is that you have
about like 100 people that you need to
keep working together but you don't
wanna run a working group of people you
wanna run you're gonna run a team a team
that works together that collaborate
with each other and that have the have a
good experience being focusing in
particular objectives so how do you do
that my I think is my biggest learning
as I went from managing one team to
money in this organization is we need to
put a lot of emphasis into structures
and infrastructure of these teams and by
that I mean a couple of things one each
team should have a charter and our
Charter is very simple it's just
something that you can articulate in
simple terms when someone come and ask
you why do you need this team why this
team needs to exist and this you should
do it at every solid layer of
instruction that you have in this case
at the pillar level or at the individual
team level and then even at the org
level why do you need a data science
organization in the first place and then
those should like bobble down if you
have shorter at the high level every
team here should be on service of that
one chart time - you should have clear
differentiation or swingline's right
like each team should have very clear
differences you should be able to
articulate why like if there's any sort
of like overlap should be able to
articulate why that overlap happens and
then have if that's a healthy overlap
which sometimes happens why or how do
you work together which takes me to the
third thing which is working agreements
and what working agreements is what to
expect from other teams and I think this
is best explained with an example so we
have these are two of the teams we have
we have notifications data science team
and that that team is just focused on
understanding how people
or which kind of notification should we
send to users and when and then you have
a data engineering team we should
actually run here or a singaporean god
who's here let's say a notification team
needs a dataset they are hey in order
for us to be able to track how people
use notifications I would like to have a
data set that says how people open
notifications by country that's it and
then their engineering team comes and
just do it they to the dataset
productionize it deserves at once
everyday celerity monitoring and
everything and that's it right well it
never happens that way I mean this team
right here is not just supporting this
team supporting this team dist in this
team all of these teams and they may be
you may even have customers outside of
this organization right so it's not like
they're not just waiting for word
they're actually flooded with work and
they need to be sure that they have a
way of doing this word in an efficient
way and that's what a working agreement
comes into place so a working agreement
here will look like and this is over
simplification how does the deranged
team receive requests do you use like we
have some sort of backlog
they are some sort of requirements do
you need like a technical design
document of that data set or do need any
sort of like prerequisites to be able to
request data set or some sort of like
data pipeline what it is LA for a
dataset request like how long does the
deranged team promise the customer that
they are gonna get back to them Alice
with an ETA and what would be the
ownership structure so who will own this
data set when they may run it and then
on what basis will this be prioritized
which is very important your support in
10 teens you have a huge backlog you
need to prioritize you should be very
very transparent about how you do that
which kind of measurement do you use to
rank what you're doing or what you
decide to ultimately to or achieve so
they have five minutes so I will go
through this quickly there's two more
things are eating a very very important
these are not that much about data
science teams so any kind of team but I
think they are just key one of them is
clear communication channels we have
monthly All Hands we actually do like
twice a year what we call data science
weeks where we invite everyone to flight
San Francisco there are scientists in
just spent a week together face-to-face
we have team meetings at team level and
a weekly basis and so on we also have
like nakeeran what we call data science
review where we just go Peter by pillar
and review all the work so we scrutinize
all the projects we leave comments
questions feedback within find ways to
collaborate with each other and then we
have fun with each other and this seems
so simple which is very very important
we do quarterly outside and they are not
just amazing because they are fun but
they are amazing because in this
informal sort of like setting it's not
like most of the conversations about
collaboration between teams happen right
you're you're not thinking about worth
that much
but somehow you end up talking about
work and then as the team grows another
lesson that I learned is that it's very
important to have to build and have a
very strong leadership team and this is
something that I didn't see at the
beginning I just saw I just thought
about managers and people managers were
responsible for this team for date teams
and I said but it's very important that
you have a team of leads and managers
who are their main team like if you're a
manager on a team that's on their data
science at Twitter your main team is not
a team that you manage is that the
leadership team and that's very key
because you need to ensure that this
function works because you need to
ensure that not just your team that
reports to you but everyone else in the
organization is working well and is
happy so we have staff meetings for
example we keep a standing agenda on
these staff meetings every week with we
talk about matrix and matrix I mean not
met not problem matrix both people
matrix my house hiding going how many on
sites we have how many open had Ron do
we have like how was the rate of
seniority on the team like how how many
junior people do we have every senior
people on the team and so on we also do
leadership off sides and these are very
work oriented we pick up on topic like
what's the vision of the organization
how do we work together like what are
the norms of the world what our
objective is this quarter and we just
like go heads down and work on that and
then we made this uterus possible for
stakeholder management which is key
typically at least
leaves up Twitter like they designed the
data science organization doesn't have
PMS but the concept man who managed to
stakeholders relationships and that's
the main difference of a data science
manager and an engineering manager would
you have that sort of like extra task of
ensuring that customers are taking care
of that you can explain to them the
decisions that you're making and so on
and this leadership team should be
responsible for that anyways quick
summary there's a bunch of ways to
structure where it depends on the
company size how eccentric they are on
engineering Prolog or other areas so an
enterprise company for example are more
like sales oriented maybe a little bit
different so we were we found so far is
a desired model between a company I mean
between our organization that reports
together on the function but work with
engineering and counterparts it has been
has given us like the best of two worlds
but which challenges you wanna line
teams with objectives and this is a
team's grow in order to scale you need
to ensure that everyone has sort of like
the same nor start on on each team and
the layer structure under you build on
top and then you wanna build a structure
the team early on so you want charters
you want swim lanes or boundaries you
want working agreement you want
communication channels all right clear
and everyone understand and you have you
want to have a very strong leadership
team right so before we go we're hiding
right in there are scientists they're
engineers engineering managers you see
yourself working on a place that
attempted to be very thoughtful about
the environment around you feel free to
see us on the ball or I'll be on the
office hours later or you can come to
our party later today and even if you're
not interested you should come prepare
alert you can find me at Mario's
Twitter my email spiegel at twitter.com
thank you
you have time for questions
thank you my name is Joshua and for
scaling data team some terms that I
heard recently is about self servicing
data scientists from your previous
slides I saw that foundation LDS seems
like fully supporting the upper layer
better science what is your opinion on
this self servicing data scientist is
there a way that the right engineer can
enables data scientist to basically
probably something like where data
scientist can get to the data source do
their own ETL and then basically do the
end-to-end by themself what's your
opinion on that let me go back to the
structure the ratio here so big part of
why we have this layer right here
I mentioned the deranged team we have a
data visualization T in the works and
tooling we have an experimentation there
are signs tuned upwards on very like
methods for experimenting and doing a/b
testing it's to ensure that the focus
here is on the data science work and
then they are enabled by these to do
exactly what you mentioned I either be
able to their own data pipelines but
also have access to data pipelines they
may need already so big part of the data
is team work is to ensure that we can if
you were a request but one day I said
how can we build that pipeline of a test
use or for many other use cases and it
that way you cannot you don't have to
think about there a scientist someone
who needs to build into N word but
there's already some tools available for
them on the other side which is more
like the reporting layer the layer of
like the layer of abstraction with a
customer we also have like the database
realization and tooling team that builds
tools and services to enable
non-technical people to do some basic
things so we have an experimentation UI
for non-technical people to see the
results of every experiment that we run
up Twitter so in that case you don't
even you don't even need a data
scientist to
you can be a p.m. a business analyst or
so on and be trained to do some of this
stuff so I would say we're trying less
to have data scientist be sort of like
end to end in terms of like have them to
everything but we want to remove some of
the wood work that is not called data
science are the way so they can focus
their day-to-day into what they can add
more value which is doing methodology
like coming up with like opportunity
size in doing some like in the in the
empanada sees and so on
hello so I will for sure loca so I think
my structure is somewhat similar to
yours my question following up his
question is I me as the data scientists
sometimes I have some frustrations with
regards to my inability to communicate
to data ingenious what and they also
share the same frustration as me and
that's what exactly either my father saw
because we don't understand each other
war flow so how do you bridge the gap in
that manner so I see and God smiling
he leads the engineering and he leads
some of our data science teams to I
think this is a stroll on our side too
and our data engineering practice is
fairly young compared to our data
science practice so we've been expanding
this team of data engineers here in
Singapore just this year so we're
learning as we do I think one working
agreements work like we're very well
because if you like if you like
entertain disagreements if you have a
working agreement so they're engineering
to entertainment with data scientists
and so on to document how you work and
so on
it just helps it helps there are
scientists understand how their
engineers work I mean we may go like
vice versa the other thing I think is
just having clear processes help too so
it's less about like understanding each
other and more like understanding what's
a glue between each other right like
which is a little bit different if you
need to collaborate I mean like the
example I just mentioned would you need
some work from each other like this back
and forth just some sort of protocol or
some sort process it helps the last
thing I'd say like one thing that we
have like since the engineering
practices so John we have like this
massive complex data set
many of our data scientists are utterly
well skill under engineering they run
their pipelines some of the best the
first things we teach there are
scientists to restore CLE to how to
build your own data pipeline and so on
and that helped era scientists to
understand like what does it take to
certain their engineering work it kind
of works vice versa where their engineer
is not someone who you strike right
calls to build their pipelines but they
also have to some analysis to do like
their equality to do some basic
understanding of the
they are building and so on so I feel
like that that overlap like if you think
about that Venn diagram you have data
engineers and there are scientists and
there's a skill set that they have in
common it helps for them to like
understand each other and work with each
other better it also helps that they
both report to the same organization so
they is similar to a dimension like that
they they are the same meetings they can
prioritize work together and so on so if
they were sitting far away in the child
the challenge would be even even bigger
that's all the time we have